So let's think of a really simple way we might solve this problem. And what I'm
going to suggest is a little like how we started. We're going to start on the
day of the first date, and we're going to just count the days, we're going to go
one day at a time. We're not going to do anything special when we go through
months, we're just going to keep counting days, keep adding as we go. And we're
going to keep doing this until we get to our target date, and I got 156. So
here's our pseudocode for, a really simple, brain-dead way of doing it. We
initialize days to 0. We have a loop that keeps going as long as date1 is
before date2. And each step we advance date1 to the next day, and we add 1 to
the number of days.